good morning everybody long day we have
about 18 bills that we're going to exec
today so we'd like to get going
immediately
representative excuse me representative
Tatro why don't you lead us in the
thank you representative
Mr clerk would you call today's roll
call please
thank you Mr chairman
Vice chairman of power present
representative Guthrie you're here
uh the clerk is here
representative lasalles here
uh representative Keller here
representative Elwood
present representative Brown here
representative Cahill
representative Davis here
representative Gilman here
representative majority here
representative mangaputi
here
representative Gallagher here
representative Hicks good morning
uh representative run here
and representative priests here and the
chairman
here thank you
thank you Mr Clark we'll get going and
open up the exact session on House Bill
Mr chairman
yes representative I'd like to move itl
on HB 489 representative lasalles moves
itl do we have a second second
representative yokelis seconds would you
like to speak to your motion
yes I I feel that there needs to be more
marketing done for the state
uh I I don't see the
effectiveness of a individual County
campaigns so I would uh I just don't
feel that this is uh
I think Representatives do we have any
seeing none unless the clerk to call the
rule
itl and Bill 489 Vice chairman of power
yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes representative Silas yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly yes
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes representative Cahill
representative Davis no
representative Tatro no
representative Trey 11.
representative Gilman no
representative majority no
representative mangaputi
no
representative Hicks no
representative wrong no
representative Priest No
and the chairman yes
motion fails uh our past is ten to nine
I'm sorry
okay thank you Mr chairman
um I assume this will not go on to the
consent calendar so we'll be looking uh
representative lasalles will write the
report
okay that closes the exact session on
House Bill 489.
open up the exact session HP 265
relative to Municipal property tax
relief for Firex suppression systems
look for a motion representative
majority
thank you Mr chair
um I reluctantly move
um I'm going to move itl on House Bill
265. thank you Miss and second
representative I will second the motion
representative Cahill seconds that
motion would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chair
um the bill is is very well intended the
the bill is intended to
um to encourage to encourage businesses
to provide an extra level of protection
in their buildings and then give them
relief for doing that however uh there's
still some technical aspects of the bill
that need to be worked out and each time
it seems like we have an amendment ready
to go to do that we find that Pandora's
Box hasn't been quite closed again and
it uh it prized itself open so at this
time it's best to itl the bill and we'll
figure out something better uh in
another time so thank you Mr chair thank
you is it further discussion
representative Gallagher
um yeah I'd like to
um
agree that it's well intentioned
um but so feedback for
um the sponsor if the sponsor hears this
um
specifically
um one
one concern was whether
um this would apply to
um
places that are required by law to
install
fire suppression systems anyways so
yeah we don't really want a tax credit
for people just doing what they have to
do anyways so um
if the prime sponsor could
take a look into that
we might be able to
um work something out for the next time
around
thank you for the comment
representative
thank you
uh see no more uh that's the clerk to
color world
HP 265 the motion is itl uh Vice
chairman power yes representative
Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes
um representative
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes representative
Brownlee yes representative Cahill
representative yes
representative tree 11 representative
Gilman yes
representative majority
yes
representative
yes representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative rung yes
representative priest yes
and Mr chairman
yes uh motion passes 19-0
19-0 passes uh any objection to the
consent calendar
seeing none it'll go on the consent
calendar and that concludes exact
uh representative majority we write the
okay we'll open up the exact session on
hb335 notice of tax lien for old age
assistants
and looking for a motion representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair I would move
HB 335 as ought to pass
representative Davis seconds would you
like to speak to your motion
representative Gilman certainly it's
very simple this just extends the amount
of time
uh in the existing law that poor notices
made
seeing none representative Gilman could
you yes thank you and we'll ask the
okay uh Bill HB 335
OTP uh Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie
click folks yes representative Visalus
yes
uh their president yukela yes
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes representative Cahill yeah
represents Davis yes representative yes
representative 11 representative Gilman
yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi
yes representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative rung yes
representative priest yes and the
chairman yes
motion passes 19-0
thank you Mr clerk 19-0 representative
Gilman will you be writing the report
thank you and uh any objection to
consent calendar
seeing none it'll go on to the consent
calendar
and that closes the exact session on
335.
open up the exact session for our house
bill 433 property tax exemptions after
sale
and looking for a motion representative
Brown
microphone sorry about that Mr chairman
I'd like to make the motion to retain at
the request of the sponsor the bill
needs some additional work
oops need a second before we speak to it
the second uh have a representative
power and representative Brown would you
now like to speak to your motion I would
Mr chairman at the request of the
sponsor the bill needs some work the
nhma is also helping them rewrite the
bill so we simply need some more time to
complete the work
seeing none It'll ask the clerk to call
it's okay okay the motion is to uh
fourth four three three retain
uh Vice human power yes representative
Guthrie
clerk votes yes representative Salas yes
uh representative yokola
yes
representative Kelly representative
Elwood yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes yes represents
Davis yes representative Tetro yes
representative 11 representative Gilman
yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
rung yes representative priest yes and
Mr chairman yes
thank you Mr clerk passes 19-0 to retain
so no committee report is necessary
and that closes the exact session on 4
33.
we'll open up the
defining qualified structure structures
and looking for a motion motion to it I
would like
uh have uh reps do you have a question
or a motion sure I had a motion the
motion is uh representative yokella uh
motion to itl is there a second second
second by representative Elwood and
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Joe Kelly
um I think that this is sure thank you
Mr chair
um I think that this is an expansion
that I'm not
um sure is warranted and
um it is just another way of uh
transferring
um the tax burden to the the
um
from from businesses to the
um people of the community trying to uh
trying to afford their tax bills so I
think that for those reasons I I think
that we should I tell this I think
representative further discussion
representative Manchester thank you Mr
chair I would be opposing itl this is
one of the ways that we can enhance the
housing as well as giving the relief
that where relief is needed and you know
revitalizing and building density and
more housing for folks is
critical at this time so this is
another tool in the toolbox so I would
oppose itl
thank you representative
thank you Mr chair and I also will be
opposing the itl motion economic
revitalization of our downtowns is a key
priority for New Hampshire
and as opposed to passing tax burdens
from businesses to
resident taxpayers I suppose is what
that means
when you rehabilitate a dilapidated
ignored crumbling property you generate
Revenue
so this would be a very good thing for
our towns and cities that have downtowns
that are blighted and the blight doesn't
always come from structures it sometimes
comes from the area around the
structures so I think that this bill
would be a very good measure for the
state to adopt thank you thank you
representative representative Gallagher
um I would just like to note that um I
am opposing the motion of itls I have an
amendment that I would like to introduce
and would like to be given
the chance to
discuss that before we move on to
discussing the bill as a whole
thank you further discussion
representative Gilman thank you Mr chair
um I would just like to add
to the itl motion that the division of
historical resources has concerns that
this will further the burden on them
they're mentioned throughout this RSA
and
I would like to see this this RSA to
thank you further discussions
seeing none could I have the clerk call
hb177 motion is itl uh Vice chairman of
power yes representative Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
I've always been
thank you uh representative of your
color Yes representative Kelly
yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes
yes represents Davis no
Representative no
representative majority no
represent mangaputi no
representative Gallagher
no
representative Hicks no
representative rung no
representative Priest No
Mr chairman yes
motion passes uh eleven to nine eleven
thank you Miss clerk uh I assume this
will not go on the consent calendar
representative Keller will you be
writing the committee report on that yes
and for the minority
report
thank you
uh
exact session House Bill 177 is closed
we'll open up the exact sessions on
hb154 adoption of Health ordinances and
do I have a motion yes Mr chair I'd like
to make a motion of ought to pass thank
you do I have a second second
foreign
and representative Cahill would you like
to speak to your motion yes I think this
is a good bill and and gives um local
control back to the people when making
decisions or what's going on in their
town
thank you representative for the
discussion representative majority
I I have respect for everybody in this
room and especially representative
Cahill but disagree in the strongest
possible way that this gives back local
control what this does is requires a
special meeting for an emergent
situation how is there any control
possible in that kind of circumstance
you would need weeks if not months to be
able to take care of an emergent
situation in your town you need local
control and this rests it away so I I
disagree and will not support the OTP
thank you
representative
I strongly agree with my colleague
representative Maggiore that this takes
away local control from municipalities
because if you have to order a boil
water a boil water order people might be
dead before they could get to a public
meeting
thank you representative further
discussion representative Tatro do you
have
can you turn your mic off please thank
you representative management thank you
Mr chair and I totally agree with my
previous two uh
representative and I totally opposed
this by taking away the local control
especially in an emergency we just come
out of uh pandemic where this was
displayed a key role for the
municipalities to have that ability to
make decisions and this will not provide
that so
that with that I will
be opposing
octopus
thank you for the discussion
seeing nonetheless the clerk to call the
hb154
OTP Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes represents lasalles yes
representative Keller
yes representative Kelly
represent Valwood yes representative
Brown yes representative Cahill yes no
representative titro
you know representative and
representative majority no represent
mangaputi no representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks no representative
rung no representative Priest No
Mr chairman yes
motion passes ten to nine thank you Mr
clerk uh representative power I
understand you'll be writing the
committee report and for the minority
and I assume that will not be going on
consent
unless you want to have it as itl and
with that we will close the
exact session on House Bill 154.
and we will now open up the exact
session House Bill 336 condominium
conversions water and sewer and
look for a motion representative Gilman
it's uh Mr chair I would like to move
itl on House Bill 236
thank you representative do we have a
second
representative majority seconds would
you like to speak to your motion yeah
actually Gilman yes thank you Mr chair I
condiment condominium conversions can
what's the word I want uh load to
existing Water and Sewer uh
areas or they will need exist improved
Wells and septic and I think it brings a
onto the towns
I could represent of any further
discussion
seeing none will ask the clerk to call
HB 236 motion is itl
Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly
yes representative
Brown yes representative Cahill yeah
perhaps Davis yes
representative Tatro yeah
Trail over now Gilman yes represent
majority yes
yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes represented
wrong yes representative priest yes and
Mr chairman yes motion passes 19-0
thank you Mr Clark without objection
let's go on to the consent calendar
seeing no objections it will go on the
consent calendar representative Gilman
we'll be writing the committee report
yes thank you
H will open the exact session on
representative I'll make a motion to
retain
um I think that
uh that
we need to uh I think that like do some
adjustment on the language and and and
uh do some uh more understanding about
what what the actual impact will be so
that's why I think that retain is uh is
the proper motion thank you
thank you representative for the
discussion
of some Gallagher
um
so
um on the lines of doing
further work on it um
I
um was under the impression that there
would be an amendment to this so I'm
wondering if we want to do further work
on it if maybe we could
vote on the amendment first and then
retain it
we can't cannot do that we have a motion
on the floor to retain I will say once a
bill is retained amendments and further
work can be
addressed
while it's retained anyway so
um further comments on this I have a
couple if you
I just want to say uh for myself the
main reason I I prefer to see this
retain is
the discussion and the
the testimony given
um for myself very confusing I know I'm
new to the committee we also have many
other new committee members here
and before I I feel comfortable voting
either direction I want to totally
understand it so I
thought the best best option at its time
would be to to retain it and get further
work that might clarify a little bit of
the language or make make things a
little easier to understand for some of
us so that was my reason for retaining
further discussion
uh representative Davis
thank you Mr chair I'll be supporting
the motion to retain although I have
spoken with both sponsors of the bill
about the amendment that I sent to OLS
the other day and distributed to the
committee yesterday and they are in
agreement with that Amendment so I would
urge our committee to take that into
consideration when we further study the
bill
thank you I totally agree further
discussion representative priests
thank you
seeing no further discussion unless the
clerk to Colorado
thank you Mr chairman uh retain on HB
202 uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes representative Salas yes
uh representative Keller yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Elwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes represents Davis yes
representative yes
uh representative Gilman yes
represent majority yes represent Mega
putty
yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
run yes
representative priest yes and Mr
chairman yes motion passes 19-0 19-0
will be retained in committee that
the next
uh exact bill that
is shown we're going to actually
I'll have to technically call it recess
it to the end of this today or whatever
we're waiting on uh an amendment that's
OLS promises is going to be here so I'd
like to wait on HP 51 until that arrives
so we will go ahead and exact open the
exact session then on HP 313 reductions
in the default budget
and let's see we asked
for emotion motion ought to pass
representative yokella moves 313
ought to pass representative power
uh Second Step motion representative
yokella would you like to speak
sure
um this is uh my build that I presented
to the committee and all it's doing is
allowing uh the default budget to
reflect the newly hired position uh when
there is turnover within uh an existing
budget so that
um it's the default budget is more
reflective of the actual status on the
ground at the time of the the public
hearing so
of the new of the new uh proposed budget
so thank you
thank you representative majority
thank you Mr chair I'm going to uh I'm
going to oppose the the ought to pass
and would prefer itl uh while I
understand certainly understand where
the prime sponsor wants to go with this
if there is a position that is unfilled
at that time through turnover having the
ability to keep that position open with
the full funding or the funding for that
position is critical to communities
should that go to the default budget
with some change for instance if the
position is unfilled then it goes to the
default budget I assume as a zero and
therefore the community would be unable
to fill that position because you would
have no money for it so I think while
while the idea is well intended I think
the consequence could be detrimental to
thank you representative further
representative Gilman
Mr chair I agree with Excuse me my
fellow representative majority I think
this is another bill or another RSA
that's been jiggled with uh many many
times including my attempt many years
ago
um I think that in today's uh climate
where it's becoming harder and harder to
fill positions I know we have several in
our public works department that have
been empty for almost a year and I've
heard that from several other
communities that leaving the um the
empty position at the at the salary
range that it was occur originally
um
budget of that will give us the
opportunity to explore different levels
of
applicants and so we're not always going
to get an applicant that is less
qualified or younger or doesn't need
health insurance so I think leaving that
um that spot at in the budget as it was
was proposed for the year or proposed
from the year before too uh that we have
more flexibility in answering our
problems
thank you representative representative
Brown
um Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
um a question that I have is a
procedural are we allowed to ask the
sponsor a clarifying question on what
was brought up by uh representative
majority
no
um okay you you are you may ask somebody
who's spoken
a question they are not required to
answer
as so Mr chairman can I ask
representative vocala a question
you can ask he is not required to answer
so if you want to go ahead and ask the
question go ahead representative you
call I'd just like to get a
clarification on that my understanding
of the language of the bill was that
um if there was a proposed position that
money could be put into the default
budget is that true or not thank you
if you want to answer go ahead thank you
representative thank you for asking the
question I completely agree that
um that a vacant position is not
turnover like turnover is when the the
definition that I'm using is that the
that turnover is when you previously had
a person and now you have a new person
that is turnover if you had a person
before and now you don't have a person
that isn't turnover yet until you
actually completed the process of hiring
a new person and so until the hiring
process has occurred then there would be
no change to the default budget and so I
completely I understand the fear of some
of the the members but I I don't believe
that is is neither the intent of the
bill nor I don't believe the application
but
if if uh definition of turnover meaning
needed to be you know clarified you know
in the senate or whatever to say that
the turnover means the hiring of an the
of a new employee that is completely
amenable to me so thank you thanks
representative
for the discussion representative status
thank you Mr chair I know we all have a
lot to remember these days
but I would like to remind my colleagues
on the community that we voted to retain
a bill
that dealt with difficulties in hiring
staff and turnover issues with the bill
with the deputy Town Clerks and so I
don't quite understand the logic of
italing this
the motion is actually
ought to pass my apologies
representative
thank you Mr chair my concern is when we
are in such a tight Market you know at
the county level at the municipality
level
this is going to take away a tool that
the municipalities and the
towns have
in order to you know you can't time a
turnover or you can't time when the
person is going to leave and there's so
much effort and time and money spent on
retaining and retraining and uh
and this will hinder that if it is not
perfectly timed by the time the budget
happens and just after the budget you
hire somebody you have to go back to put
that money back into that so just I
think looking at what we have in this
situation right now
Workforce
Development High you know Workforce is
such acute shortage and this will only
affect
putting a good budget so I will oppose
ought to pass so we can keep that tool
that the municipalities need thank you
representative lasalles
yes the whole um discussion of the
default budget is I feel there's a lot
of
frustration on the part of taxpayers
that they go into the voting booth and
vote against a budget
that they feel is too high
and if that budget fails
the fallback position which is the
default budget in many cases is higher
than the than the budget that they just
voted against so
I am in favor
of
changing the formula
for the default budget
to more adequately reflect the intent
of what the default budget should be
which is a fallback position in case the
operating budget fails so in my case I I
don't think this is a perfect bill but
I'm in favor of it
representative majori
thank you Mr chair and
um I I agree I agree with my friend from
across the aisle on what you're saying
and I agree with the prime sponsor still
in in what the goal is but I think the
language and creates a question and has
with my own Financial director say and
he brought up two or three examples of
well what if and I couldn't answer it I
know exactly where you want to go I just
don't I think this bill is going to
leave some question marks which are yet
unanswered if they can be answered if
this bill were to get to the Senate I
think we would have something better but
at this point right here with this
language I can't support it so thank you
representative priest thank you Mr
chairman
um I agree with the intent of this
sponsor but I think the language in the
bill is very vague and I will be voting
against the ought to pass and will be
opting for to retain this bill so this
can be clarified
and and we can move it on
thank you thank you
so you know further questions or
comments ask the clerk to call the role
khb 313
ought to pass Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
clerk votes yes represent lasalles yes
representative Keller yes
representative Kelly
yes representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes representative stavis
no
representatro no
representative Gilman
no
represent majority no
Representative no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks no
representative rung no
representative Priest No
uh
sorry where was I
yes
do I have another motion represent
freeze Mr chairman I move that this uh
bill is retained in committee so we can
clarify the issue of temporary and
staff thank you
thank you do I have a second on that
second
for the discussion point of order
representative stavis thank you Mr chair
I'd just like to inform the clerk that's
ation
you know
so you know further discussion we're
going to ask the clerk to call a role on
HB 313 motion is retained Vice chairman
representative Guthrie
click votes yes representative Salas yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes
representative Cahill yes Davis yes
representative yes representative 11.
yeah
representative Gilman yes representative
majority
yes representative yes representative
Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
represented wrong yes
representative priests
and Mr chairman yes
motion passes 20 to zero okay so passes
20 to zero no committee report required
it will be retained in committee that
open up the exact session on HB 270
commissioner districts for Stratford
County
do I have a motion representative Cahill
yes I make a motion to ought to pass H
Bill 270. thank you representative do I
have a second I'll second that
representative LaSalle seconds would you
like to speak to your motion
representative Cahill
yes thank you Mr chair
this is a fantastic bill
um that brings all of our counties in
line together as Stratford county is the
only County without districts and uh
this is a fantastic bill and I move to
octopaths
thank you representative for the
there's a very very little that is
consistent about our counties and far
from bringing our counties into
consistency and together I think this
bill
divides Republicans and Democrats in a
unfortunate and I I think that what we
see and what we have seen traditionally
on this Committee in particular is
Republicans and Democrats working
together for the betterment of the
citizens of our state and I see this
bill as a partisan divisive
issue and I will be voting against it
thank you thank you for the comments
representative Gallagher
um so
I'd just like to note that um I followed
up on my question about the distance
between the tip of Madbury and
um the next County over Rockingham
County
um with a geographer and found out that
that is in fact an example of point
contiguity and even if Point continuity
May
technically be legal I still find it to
be in extremely bad taste and think it's
sure it makes an example of
gerrymandering so um I am going to
oppose the
and oppose the motion of OTP on this
bill
thank you for the discussion yes
representative lasalles
one of the worst things that can happen
in my mind in a representative democracy
is to feel as if your vote doesn't count
we had significant testimony when we
went through from the rule rural
portions of the county that they just
didn't feel as if their vote counted
that the cities were because of the
population dispersions the city's
overwhelmed the rural portions and it it
meant that the these people
were frustrated that they just didn't
have the the the vote so
when you do redistricting it is
inherently political you can't take the
politics out of it so to and I respect
my
colleague Representatives Davis who who
said that this is a a a a very partisan
effort here and I don't disagree with
that because it is redistricting
uh with respect to representative
Gallagher's uh discussion of the
contiguity
it is it meets the the Constitutional
definition of contiguous so I don't see
that that is a valid argument so I will
be supporting the OTP here and hopefully
these people in the rural portions of
the county will will feel as if their
vote matters
foreign
thank you Mr chair sorry for my
chartiness I was driving around the
block but not for two hours
um I am not in support of this bill for
a number of reasons and I heard from
many constituents at least a dozen via
email and voicemail messages and phone
conversations who are all residents of
Stratford County
feeling
that this is not an appropriate time to
do this redistricting first of all that
this um this effort is not transparent
and really not although we did hear from
people just as my friend representative
LaSalle said we did hear from people in
the more rural parts of the county that
they were dissatisfied
we didn't hear from everyone and we did
we've now heard from more people now
that the bill is out
um
transparency is what I'm hearing and
that that's not happening right now the
second part that I've been hearing is
how can we be redistricting a county
here in the state legislature
when it's
it it's not the right times is what
people are saying to me the um the fact
that we've just had the census done
and it will be another
several years till a new census is done
that seems to be the appropriate time to
put in a measure that would redistrict
Stratford County to potentially meet the
um
same standards as our other Counties
have the other part that I'm hearing is
Stratford county is unique in the fact
that it is the smallest one of the
smallest counties that we have
and yet it's the fourth most populated
county and we haven't spoken to enough
or listened to enough of our
constituents to get a true picture of
what it is they're looking for
so I will not be in support of this bill
and I'm not going to read you
all the emails that I got from people
but they are basically saying what I've
just said it needs to be a transparent
process the people need to have lots
more input than they've had and the
decision needs to be
um much broader and right now we're not
there that's all I'll say for now thank
you
for the comments
representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair I will Echo some of
the same sentiments uh my colleague just
spoke and this we heard from other
Commissioners from other counties and
from my county that says you know we
have heard it several times making
um
comment about taking a bite of the Apple
twice and this is one example where the
redistricting the Statewide
redistricting commission did all those
things for the 2020
um you know between 2020 and 2022 and
just because it didn't match up to what
uh some of the voters in that county
felt uh disenfranchised to say that
we're going to redistrict just that
county for just that purpose is taking a
second bite just because
um you can do it so I think the
transparency the Democratic process and
also making it more partisan all the way
down to the local level where several
Commissioners who spoke said it's a
non-partisan issue the voters selected
the Commissioners and if the density of
population
that happens to be in the cities where
it that's where it is in the economic
engine is from these densely populated
uh part of the county so are these
Waters less of a choice just because
they pay more taxes or contribute I just
don't get it so just trying to make this
divisiveness I will oppose the art pass
this has to wait for the next redistrict
representative power thank you Mr
chairman with all due respect I I
disagree with the notion that this bill
is about redistricting
it's it's putting in place
districts at the county level and in New
Hampshire All Counties have three
Commissioners I see this as I said it's
it's about putting in districts and it's
about how these Commissioners are voted
upon
currently it's at large versus
the voters within a district which don't
yet exist being able to elect the
commissioner for their District
and furthermore redistricting has to do
with apportionment
of Voters and representation
um
The Spill to me is not that
representative
thank you Mr chair I feel like I'm
having deja vu all over again
but um
the chair kindly offered to work on a
newer version or a different version of
a bill that came before this committee
that was sponsored by me earlier and I
think I'm making the same request of him
now
I feel as though we have a difference of
opinion amongst us as as to whether this
constitutes redistricting and therefore
can the Apple be bitten again and I
think the answer is probably no to that
uh but clearly there are people in this
County who feel disenfranchised that's a
bad thing I agree with my called week
representative lasalles
there has to be a way of fixing this
problem for counties across New
Hampshire it's one of the things we as a
committee grapple with over and over and
over again and I wonder if this might be
an opportunity to retain and really take
representative Gallagher
um so as to the question of whether this
is redistricting or not uh I think this
bill has two separate parts one is to
say that Stratford County shall have
districts and then the other is to
actually draw those districts and I'm
just questioning why we have to do those
two things combined like I think another
possible solution is if we just
want Safford County have districts we
could say
Trafford County Sheriff districts which
will then be drawn by an independent
redistricting commission or which shall
then be drawn by the county delegation
or the County Commissioners but instead
we're drawing those districts ourselves
here which I think shows that this is in
fact redistricting rather than one of
representative Cahill
um would it be okay if I asked the prime
sponsor a question
the prime sponsor will speak after
and if I don't answer your question
after that
sure
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair
um one I would actually
um be in support of retaining this bill
because if you look at the other
sections about how County
um
Commissioners sorry elected it's kind of
a flip of this bill where the the
district is defined and then the terms
of the county officials and how they're
voted comes after that and we've been
changing the Commissioners slowly but
surely to four-year terms so that might
also be a consideration here and
describe how they're voted uh you know
which commission has the four-year term
first and then the others would be two
and one or something like that so I I
would vote to retain on retain this to
uh I can't say oh rep uh sorry
representative wrong go ahead that's
okay thank you Mr chair I'm just
wondering why there's no fiscal note on
this bill because there would be a cost
to the county to to form those districts
and set up the election things like that
I I would think there'd at least be a
okay
representative priests
thank you Mr chairman um
a couple of my friends who live in these
rural areas in Stratford County when
they heard what was happening was very
alarmed they're independent voters
um
and they said there's a better process
of doing this and they didn't feel like
there were not being heard or
represented they instead they did feel
like their existing system
existing Commissioners we're hearing
them and we're representing the entire
County
for the whole welfare of the county but
they felt like if this was needed there
would be there should be a time where
there the residents event uh independent
commission would come up with the
boundaries for the three Commissioners
instead of having it done in this
committee
thank you
thank you Representatives Davis
Mr chair could you refresh my memory do
we have a motion on the floor we have a
motion on the floor
ought to pass
can we vote on that motion and then
we still have people making comments
representative treeleven
thank you Mr chair my Mike's been on
this whole time good thing I was quiet
um one thing that I forgot to mention uh
two of the folks who contacted me
said why is this in front of our
committee and I had that question as
well
um Municipal and County government the
name of our committee might make sense
yet these people both asked me why it
wasn't in election law since those folks
have more experience with that that's
all thanks thank you for the comments
seeing that I'll make a few and answer
some questions
the first point of this bill and
representative Gilman kind of talked
about how it appears to be reversed it's
just the way I believe the rsas are
written and that's how olus wrote it up
um one of the issues that myself and the
vice chair and I assuming most on this
committee are concerned with and that's
consistency and in one of the rsas
contained in the bill it says starts out
except for Stratford County
and then it goes on in that IRS say to
delineate every other County and their
districts
that's the first point
second point a person apportionment
versus districting or redistricting
apportionment is the 10-year
um
we do every 10 year after the census
numbers are given this past term we were
very delayed on the census and the
district
redistricting was quite a bit delayed
um
apportionment is when they take the
numbers they assign them to a town or
Ward or whatever and then
the districts are redrawn using those
numbers
um
I heard talk about a lot of emails I too
got a lot of emails from people all over
the county including the city saying
this somebody asked about why this
committee
I would ask the same thing
um as you know well some of you know I
was on the redistricting committee for
the State uh for the
in the house last term
and um all of that went through
the election law I will say in 2006
there was a bill put forth similar to
this where they tried to put districts
into Stratford County and that came that
was also before this committee as to why
it was assigned here I don't have a a
um
the next thing this is not redistricting
this is a districting of the county
I've heard we have we heard the
commissioner of Stratford County last
week testified that this was
unconstitutional because of
apportionment and redistricting he was
either totally in error not knowing the
law and the Constitution or he was maybe
attempting to mislead this committee it
is not in fact I went to the Secretary
of State yesterday and had a discussion
on HB 270 and he said indeed what you
were doing is not only lawful and
Constitution but he understands it I
asked him about redistricting versus
District he said this is not a
redistricting you were more than
I brought a little prop today I just
wanted to show you
so you have an idea when I I think I
spoke last week when we were talking
about the redistricting committee about
the legalities the constitutionality
when we were on the redistricting
committee last year this is the book we
were given and this this delineates all
the U.S constant U.S Supreme Court
decisions on
redistricting
I couldn't find one in here that even
deals with Commissioners and I will say
when we went around to each County last
year
had listening sessions every County the
redistricting committee went to at least
once and we had held several
um
the
numbers of people who showed up
were minimal
and on top of that the comments
that they made were on the U.S House cd1
cd2
and then their County redistricting in
terms of their state representatives I
never heard one question about
commissioners
Commissioners districts
were for the existing ones were redrawn
never received a single comment on a
commissioner's District
when it comes to redistricting
the con the
the ease of drafting a commissioner's
district is much more simple
than
uh
State reps as an example Stratford
County County we're talking about
three Commissioners very easy to to
develop count districts there think
about trying to fit 38 Representatives
into that same same area much more
difficult so this is not
this is this is not a
something that is extremely extremely
difficult
um
trying to think of some of the other
questions or comments that were made did
I end I can't remember if I answered
representative cahills yet
um
I think that's all I have somebody
mentioned the cost there will be no
costs I spoke with OLS somebody last
time talked about
this is not
saying we need to have a new election
for commissioners
what it's saying is the next time the
election cycle comes around we will be
electing Commissioners to districts
within Stratford County so there will
not be any additional
costs involved with that
and that's it for now
represents Davis
thank you Mr chair I hear that you're
clearly passionate about your bill
and I wish that we could vote on the
bill
thank you
seeing no further questions we're going
to have the clerk call the roll
yes
okay go ahead
thank you Mr chair I appreciate it
um I I want to reiterate
the message that I got from the people
who talked to me and emailed me and left
me messages about transparency and about
the fact that the input for changing
something that's worked in Stratford
County for decades
um they weren't they weren't asked about
it not broadly enough not widely enough
and I understand that people don't often
come to
listening sessions when they don't think
there's a big problem but when something
is going to be changed then they see
that there may be a problem and they
they speak up about it and I really want
to be listening
to those people uh who who are speaking
okay
um
yes representative priest I would like
to Echo the comments that were expressed
by the previous representative
I think there is no transparency in this
and to really further and to make this a
districting plan that we that the
chairman wants we should
retain this or put it into a study
committee and reach out to all of the
communities and the residents and get
their input on this matter thank you
okay on that comment I've I've heard
this uh several times now this bill has
been out for two months
people have more than enough time to
come and testify we received an email
everybody received a an email from a
gentleman involved with a
advocacy group I'll call it that
talking about a lot of the issues that
y'all are bringing up the same
individual
who
casually suggests
down at the bottom of his page that you
redistricting plans are under challenge
in court would he failed to mention in
that email was that he and his group a
very partisan although he calls it
bipartisan group
is the one who has filed those lawsuits
also
there were many things that he put in
here were just totally wrong talking
about the unconstitutionality of it much
like the commissioner mclaris did it's
fine when people send out information
but when they send out information
that's totally wrong I mean that's
that's another
another thing we we keep hearing how
this has worked in our County it has not
obviously the people who knew about it
and took the time that came out come out
and spoke about it they were adamantly
speaking adamantly for the bill and
letting it be known that they did not
feel this has been working for Stratford
County for a very long time uh
representative Davis
Mr chairman can we vote on this bill
please
representative Cahill has a question
first
I was going to rescind my question and
just make a statement
um if that's okay absolutely go ahead
our original state seal has a bundle of
five arrows on it representing the then
five counties we've got to a place where
we have more counties we've changed
things over and over throughout history
in this state and I think In fairness we
need to actually
vote on this bill ought to pass for
these people have this problem
thank you representative seeing no
further comment we will ask the clerk to
call the world
HP 270 is OTP uh Vice chairman power yes
click votes yes representative Salas yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly
representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yeah
yeah represents Davis no
representative Tatro no representative
tree 11.
no
representative Gilman no representative
majority my mind has been changed no
Representative no representative
Gallagher
no representative Hicks no
representative wrong no representative
Priest No and Mr chairman yes
motion is a tie at 10 10.
uh representative like to make a motion
uh State emotion and move to retain this
bill
uh representative Staples makes a motion
to retain do we have a second
Is there further comment
yes representative only to just very
briefly paraphrase and repeat what I
said before that this is a committee
that deals with the the nuts and the
bolts of how counties and municipalities
work this bill presents us with an
excellent opportunity to as I said do a
deep dive into this issue which is
clearly a divisive issue and I think
that as a committee our charge is to
deal with these issues and we ought to
deal with them as presented in this bill
uh representative majority
thank you Mr chair
um I was prepared to vote in favor of
this bill when we first heard it for
reasons that I've heard I I've ever
since I've been on this committee I've
talked about consistency in our
community in our in well in all of our
communities and certainly our counties
um but I've heard things here today that
that
um I'm not sure the transparency is the
word that I want to use so much as I
like the word Deep dive this may be the
right thing to do and this may be the
right way to do it I'm convinced that
it's it's perfectly legal to do it
having done the research on the
difference between creating the
districts and redistricting
um but I I fully support the idea of
retaining it to make sure that it has
been fully vetted and has had as much
input as possible thank you thank you
representative
seeing no more hands raised we'll ask
the clerk to call
the role
HP 270 motion is to retain uh Vice
chairman power no
representative Guthrie
nope
Representative no
representative Kelly
foreign
no representative Brown no
Representatives Davis yes representative
yes
representative Gilman yes
well for the majority yes representative
yes representative Gallagher yes
representative
representative priest yes
and Mr chairman no
motion passes 11 to 9.
okay then the motion to retain uh
so where do we stand with this bill now
it's retained in committee
okay so it doesn't go to the floor and
representative majority thank you Mr
chair I also have a question of the
chair just for process when we retain a
bill is it indefinitely essentially to
the end of our the next term or do we
have a deadline for when we have to take
action there is a deadline I believe it
will be in the fall and then we
um
the the bill will go with a
recommendation to the floor at the
for the comments
sorry go ahead thank you I do want to
make a comment
um
I originally was going to vote no to
retain because I don't think it's a very
still it's not a very good bill
um and working on it I just want to be
sure that we are all mindful of the fact
that there's a whole bunch of people we
need to listen to and talk to
um listen more than talk maybe going
forward that's all thanks thank you
exact session on HB 270 is closed and we
will
open up the exact session on HB 294
enabling municipalities to adopt a child
tax credit
yes Mr chair I'd like to make a motion
to itl HB 294.
representative Cahill makes a motion to
itl do I have a second second
who was the second representative you
Keller
and would you like to speak to your
motion thank you Mr chair yes I think
that this bill definitely would shift um
taxes it has a lot of unintended
consequences
foreign
thank you representative Gallagher
um I would
just like to note that I have an
amendment to this bill and would like to
have a chance to discuss it
so for that reason
um I will be opposing the motion of itl
just so that
we can
have a chance to discuss my Amendment
thank you representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman my comment was
that uh as any uh
abatement if you will uh our credit uh
that goes to a particular group in a
community uh there always is the issue
and the concern that the uh you know
John paying for Miri uh and I I know
that's a considered we can can't get
away from and I was surprised I happened
to take this uh Bill to my uh Tom clerk
who I have a great deal of respect
perspective for and she was I told her I
was going to get it for her and she was
all upset because of that those concerns
and once she read the bill I think she
thought it had a lot of Merit and
because it was enabling she was not
uncomfortable with it I think my and I
personally think that this bill is ahead
of its time I think it's something
that's going to go come
uh to the communities for their
consideration sometime in in the future
but uh I I don't see it uh being
accepted by uh any communities uh if it
was brought forward to them but having
said that I think
it's something that's going to happen
we're going to get to the position where
we now have uh part-time kindergarten uh
and it's just uh children are going to
the kindergarten based on the lottery
uh and you know that seems to be kind of
unfair and what do we do those people
who didn't win the lottery
uh maybe uh they need some consideration
so I think it's I need some discussion I
think it's uh probably something that's
going to happen uh after my time
but I I appreciate the uh the bill when
I'm going to have to even though it's
enabling I'm going to have to vote
against it I think it's just as
something that's not going to be
accepted
thank you Mr chairman representative
service
thank you very much Mr chair
I am in sympathy with the intent of this
bill
I have numerous issues with the
technical aspects of it there is no
means testing in this bill as there are
for other tax exemptions and credits
that we Grant to other populations
there is also a section in the bill that
deals with landlords and and but it is
not clear at all how the landlords are
to pass on the child tax credits to
their tenants there's no mechanism by
which that can be measured so
theoretically a landlord could rent to
tenants with kids and reap the rewards
of the child tax credit without passing
that along to the tenants
which seems uh absurd on its face to me
um
and there was another issue with it I
was I see even though it is enabling
the means testing is where I just stop
in my tracks because if Elon Musk moved
to Lebanon and this was enacted and we
enabled it through our city council Elon
musk's would get a tax credit if he had
more kids and that's just unacceptable
for the comments representative majority
I feel like I'm heaping on but I would
also note that the bill has technical
flaws that haven't been addressed even
even if the amendment was introduced
there's another technical flaw you can't
have a percentage in the bill it has to
be a fixed dollar amount dra can operate
with with the idea of any percentage
they they need they need guard rails so
uh the the bill may be well intended and
ahead of its time but it is not ready
for the comments
seeing none unless the clerk to call a
roll
HB 294 itl Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
clerk votes yes
representative lasalles yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly yes
representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes representative stavis yes
representative titro yes representative
Trey Levin yes representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Hicks yes
representative rung yes representative
priest yes
and Mr chairman
I am going to join representative
uh 18 to 2 the motion passes thank you I
assume this will any objections to the
consent calendar
seeing none it'll go on the consent
calendar
and uh
who who made the original motion
representative Cahill will you write the
thank you
open the hearing on Executive
session on HB 423 accessory dwelling
units use spot Allowed by right
and looking for a motion representative
priests
is there an amendment that has been
is there a second on would you why don't
you make a motion on the amendment
I'm sorry Mr chairman I move that the
amendment
2023-0538h be adopted
is there a second representative manager
Puti seconds
would you like to speak to it
again
um we have a housing crisis in this
state and I feel like this is one of the
tools that is needed in those
communities with water and sewer I think
the zoning and the contextual
concerns will all be addressed with the
local
zoning controls and if they aren't they
should be
um and I feel like this is an important
tool and I think this amendment would
just a limited to those areas with water
and sewer thank you
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair I'd just like to
point out in the amendment there appears
to be an error
in the last line such accessory units
shall only be permitted on Lots served
by Municipal City and Sewer
representative yokella
thank you Mr chair
um as I'm just looking at this this
amendment it looks like it is
[Music]
um
amending the
section of law which previously granted
um accessory dwelling units as a matter
of right and now is saying that such
accessory dwelling units shall only be
and then the error
um I think that this is actually a step
back because I think it
um it would not it would restrict what
is currently a right of all
properties in the state to just the
accessory dwelling
um
that is already allowed to be changed to
just allowed on um Lots served by
Municipal City
water and sewer and so
um while I think this this uh
needs I think what what this really
needs is this bill needs to be retained
or um or tabled in some some aspects so
that this committee and or the committee
on housing can really do the work
necessary to
um uh address the needs of the housing
in the state and
um while I I believe this this amendment
is well intentioned I think that
um it just it it's it signals that there
is a knee is the willingness to work on
this issue
um and so for that reason I think that
we should um
further comments representative
Gallagher
um so yeah I would like to
um Echo representative
yokella's concern about this possibly
being a step backwards
um I'm thinking
um instead of shall only be permitted
the better wording might be so only be
required to be permitted
um but
yeah that's something that we would that
that would that could be an alternative
Amendment
that
um we would discuss after retaining
um
so
yeah um I
I think
this amendment I think the bill
um
yeah I I don't think that this
particular amendment is the right way
forward for this bill but I would like
to see the underlying bill
um succeed and hope that we can have a
chance to help it do that
representative Hicks
I wholeheartedly support representative
yokelo's comments
thank you for the comments
representative thank you Mr chair I
support I mean I'm talking about the
procedural thing this happened to me a
couple of terms ago when there was a
error on the amendment and uh the
committee at that time recessed and I
got a change and corrected and brought
it back after lunch which I'm looking at
the clock it's getting to be close to
that is there a way instead of retaining
it for a whole
year and bring it back with the right uh
Amendment because this is a critical
piece that we need to address the
housing shortage any number of ways that
we can do to help alleviate this is not
the only answer this is one of many
tools and we are desperate with housing
need and instead of retaining it for the
whole year if there's a way that we
representative priests
thank you Mr chairman this is a question
to the chair what is the procedure when
we
receive an amendment and there's errors
that we find in the discussion of it
um
as far as I'm concerned on this we will
proceed with a vote on what exists it's
up to the individual who's bringing the
amendment forward to make sure that that
bill is properly vetted and correct
which brings us to the point of a lot of
times we get these amendments very very
last minute not a big fan myself from
either side because it does it's really
doesn't give us proper time
you know to vet the actual Amendment but
uh so we'll as far as I'm concerned
we'll continue to vote on the amendment
as it is
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
letting me make my comments I happen to
come from a community as that has
neither Municipal Water or soup
uh so you know all these things that are
being tried for the housing is sort of
on the side because it almost in every
case
it's a it's a given that if you don't
have sewer and water
then it's a local matter and you better
keep that local control there because if
you require towns that have that don't
have serum water to do things that might
impact adversely on their sewer and
water
it's pretty much given that that we
don't want to do that and that plus the
so I I'm I'll be in favor of the
amendment but I can't vote for the bill
so it's kind of a funny situation but I
I will vote for the uh the the article
because I think that's the direction all
these bills should go to go through but
I can't vote for the article uh in uh a
matter of a right instead of uh option
thank you Mr chairman
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman I have a question
for representative priests you can
choose to answer this or not I'm just
trying to figure out how this amendment
uh was going to how you felt this
amendment itself was going to fix the
the problem with the the bill maybe you
could just clarify a little bit please
representative priest you may answer
that if you'd like yes I will thank you
Mr chairman there was concerns when this
was discussed last week about
imposing additional housing units in
areas where and on on lot sizes that
were not sufficiently you know adequate
with water with their own Wells and
septic tanks so that's what I thought it
would be more appropriate just to limit
the adus in areas where there was Public
Water and Sewer
and Mr chairman
but representative Tatro
thank you Mr chair
um coming from a community that
does not have
water and Municipal City
water or sewer
um this would take the communities I
represent right out of the
the housing auxiliary unit
Market
um
and
with all the talk of
not having enough housing seems to me
this is negative against
making more housing
and also discriminatory because the
eliminating towns that don't have
um
accessory municipal
sewer and water
and the property owners may have enough
land
to comply with state law and that's
already
square footage
of
septic systems Plus
location of the Well Service so I I
cannot support this
representative Davis
thank you Mr chair I seek the wisdom of
should I retract that
now and honestly I do and and I want to
respond
in my comments to something of
representative yakella said the Speaker
of the House in his wisdom has created a
special housing committee
clearly this is a bill that needs to be
examined by this special housing
committee what is the proper procedure
from our perspective as a committee
to get it from our committee to the
special housing committee that is an
excellent question which I do not have
the answer to you would have to speak
with the speaker all I know is that we
will be dealing with this bill in
committee
representative priests
uh Mr chairman thank you um I I do have
a question a procedural question
um is it permissible for me to withdraw
my emotion on this amendment and to
offer one that retains it so we can get
this and other concerns addressed you
can always
um
take back your
your Amendment as long as the second
approves it and then we will be back to
another motion
representative priest now is it proper
for me to withdraw the motion now you
can do that thank you I would like to
withdraw the motion for Amendment
2023-05 38-h so we can uh clar uh
correct the mistake on this amendment
and also clarify other issues thank you
who was the second
was the second are you willing to
withdraw your second
I would but can I make a quick comment
and ask you can either we got to move
this along either yay or nay do you want
to I will withdraw
okay very good can I make a comment the
motion no no you cannot uh right now we
will take another motion is there a
motion
representative Gallagher
uh I would like to
um move to recess the executive session
um on this bill for an hour
um so we can get lunch and then
um come back don't believe that's a
motion oh that could be for me we're
looking for a motion on the bill we've
opened up the hearing on HB 423 uh
representative McDonald do you have a
motion yes no representative McDonald
moves itl on HB 423 do we have a second
a second representative Cahill seconds
we have very limited uh water and sewer
treatment and this would probably cost
my community to replace that plant
probably 50 to 100 million dollars to
build a bigger plant to treat these new
houses now we've got a master plan that
spells out how many properties we can
develop on I think this is just about my
community
thank you for the comments uh
representative uh yeah representative
Hicks thank you Mr chairman
um this is a bill that I'm conflicted on
um I want to support this bill I I have
problems with this
um
I feel this is opening the gates to even
more adus in the future
I don't know what people will do with
with those adus
I know in my neighborhood there's great
opposition to this
including a constituent in my own
household
I disagree with that constituent
because we need more housing desperately
but that said constituent also said fine
then we will rent it out and help pay
our mortgage
um and that is not in the spirit of this
I don't believe and she meant short-term
rental
so as much as I want to support this I
don't think this is the right form of
this bill
thank representative representative
color thank you for recognizing me
um I
um disagree with representative McDonald
we didn't have any um Amendment having
to do with Municipal Water and Sewer so
I believe those comments were
um relevant to the bill at hand and I
also
um
uh you know I believe that that one of
the uh that there is a lot of I believe
that there is a lot of
um
uh support for working on this by the by
the fact that the chair of the housing
committee is in attendance right now and
the um and the sponsor of the bill is is
um you know in attendance uh rushing to
go get amendments
um even as far as today
um and so I just believe that um in
answer to representative stavis's
comment about how do we get this from
our committee to the housing committee
it would be a motion to vacate
from this committee on the floor and of
the house and then to recommit to the
housing and the housing board or the
housing committee is
um you know going to I believe meet
regularly and and going to be doing deep
Dives in this type of issue and so I
agree with the with the representative
that this is the proper place and
um will give the work have the time to
do the work the Deep dive work that
needs to be done on this and so while of
course I would be in favor of retaining
in this committee I would also be in
favor of vacating to the housing
committee also which I don't believe can
be made in this at this time but could
be made on the house floor
um next week when we meet again
thank you uh representative Gallagher
uh yeah so just as representative
yokello was noting with um some of our
audience members in attended to say I
was wondering if we could have
um Prime sponsor read recognized to help
us clear up some of the questions that
we had about this bill
let's add a question of the chair yes
that's a question after the chair uh no
we are going to continue with this bill
representative man japoodi thank you Mr
chair
um I would
suggest
this is my feeling on this Bill yes I am
a co-sponsor of this and if instead of
itla if you're not willing to do it
right here in the committee send it to
the floor
as ought to pass and bring a floor
Amendment and then vacate it to wherever
it needs to go if we are not willing to
do that right here in our committee at
least give this chance because this is a
very important tool that we need to
increase the housing and if that is
agreeable there's enough support if we
can instead of belaboring here and
retaining it move it forward I think
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman
I would suggest that the housing
committee has eyes and ears and it's not
necessarily to vacate we just take
action on this this uh whether we want
to retain it or uh
i.tell it and they I'm quite sure that
as I said they have eyes and ears I
don't think it's necessary to vacate
representative Davis
thank you Mr chair
I think this is not a
very important conversation I appreciate
the chair giving us time to have this
conversation
um I frankly don't know whether this is
a good bill or not there are good parts
to it there are not so good parts to it
one of the issues that worries me
about the special committee on housing
is how will it dovetail with the work
that we do on a daily basis in Municipal
and County Government
how will the laws that undergird
the way our counties and municipalities
run
be assured that they are not trampled
upon
in a rush to develop more housing when
maybe those areas in which that housing
is thought to be developed are not
appropriate for that area but may be
more appropriate for another area so
that's a concern I have and I also would
like to offer another suggestion
that we take a vote on the bill that we
debated on the floor or table it in
which case it can be pulled off the
table
and reconsidered by either our committee
or another committee but I think that it
it appears obvious to me that we are not
equipped or prepared to dispose of this
bill today
representative Brown
uh Mr chairman just a clarification I
believe representative McDonald made a
motion I don't I didn't hear a second so
I'm just concerned that we have a motion
on the floor yes
what's up okay there is a motion of ital
so I guess I just asked if we could uh
representative majority
thank you Mr chair
um I'm I'm so conflicted on on how to
get this to the right people because I
still have questions I I asked the
question in committee when when
testimony was given that that this this
is only a step towards and I forget the
exact words uh that that the that the
witness used and I asked well can you
tell me how how many units we have added
or how much the one Adu mandate has it
has helped the situation and the answer
is we don't have those stats so I asked
well then how does doubling this to two
help if we don't have any stats I'm more
than happy to support something that
helps housing but I have to be able to
report back to my community and say
which by the way has told me not to
support this but say this will help in
this way so I just however we can get it
to the right people I'm all for that
thank you
representative uh
X
thank you Mr chairman I just want to be
clear that um if
I support the Ito motion it does not
mean that I want to kill this bill
entirely and so that's a difficult thing
for me I do think that this should be
continue to be studied
representative wrong
thank you Mr chair
um I support the itl
um I I really support expanding our
housing and I think accessory dwelling
units can be a tool to that but the way
this bill is now
in my day job on the resources committee
one of the things that we've been
hearing a lot about are failed Wells
that Wells are being overused in a
drought situation we have catastrophic
well failures throughout the state and
we have a couple bills in front of our
committee now on that so I think any
bill that this committee is considering
to add housing onto an existing lot I
think it would be appreciated and
helpful to have a a component of that
bill ensure that if that accessory
dwelling unit is relying on an existing
well that there be a hydrological study
to ensure that that well can support
that that additional population or the
additional residency on the lot but as
it is now it doesn't have that safety
for the comments seeing none we'll call
okay HB 423 the motion is itl uh Vice
chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes represent lasalles a
reluctant yes
representative Keller
hard no
representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes
representative stavis a very reluctant
yes
okay represent 311 no
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
Representative no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks I'm gonna go no
representative priests
no
representative uh chairman yes
okay the motion passes I tell fourteen
to six representative McDonald I assume
you were right at the committee report
yes very good and I will write The
wolf wolf is fight over it but but
someone will someone will write a
Minority Report it's going to go on the
floor not no no uh we'll look for
direction on that from
the minority individuals on the
I am part of the minority of the vote so
yeah
I will not minority on the vote
representative Keller the minority
senior members of the minority committee
not the vote
so
the mind the senior member of the
minority of the committee voted to
to itl they weren't part of the the
minority of the committee on this vote
correct but she will get the final
decision on who writes the committee
report okay
if if that's you that's fine but
representative I don't I I just that's
fine I understand your position
and that closes the exact session
exact session on 423
[Music]
it looks like we have
one two three four five we've got about
six more representative priests
yes could this be taken off of the
consenta
it's not it's not on the consent
I I assumed it wouldn't go on the
all right so
um we have six more to go I don't think
we can do those in 10 minutes so why
don't we break until 1 30 that gives
everybody an hour and we'll come back
everything
foreign
okay folks we're gonna get going here
um we'll go open up the exact session on
representative priest I like a motion
that we uh OTP
um bill
HB 467.
do we have a second representative
would you like to speak to emotion yes I
would
um the reason why I think access
to any park is essential well designed
we're all well constructed and I think
it's essential if you have any
disabilities physical disabilities
um and and are handicapped and I have a
personal experience I would like to
share with you because I have a nephew
who has physical disabilities and I see
him
um on
Pathways that are not accessible and
they don't mean the F the ADA
requirements and it's just heartbreaking
so I think this bill kind of rectifies
it thank you
thank you
do we have any other comments
representative power
thank you Mr chairman I I do
um believe that it it is important to
have public playground accessibility
um for all people
however due to the fact that there are
already Federal requirements
to have surfaces that allow for
accessibility to these playgrounds I
don't see the need for this bill
so yeah I'd be voting against OTP
thank you representative
thank you Mr chair
um we did hear in testimony when we when
you heard this bill
um that the while the Ada is terrific
and requires many things it does not
take into account variations in climate
and what we heard from those who
testified and supported this bill is
that the harsh New England Winters wreak
havoc on the kind of filler that is used
to make playgrounds elsewhere in the
United States accessible rendering them
unaccessible for people with physical
handicaps in New Hampshire so I will be
supporting the ought to pass motion
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman uh I wasn't here
but I did look at some of the test mode
in regard to some like question that I
have is how is this uh funded uh Beyond
what's already required by the Ada
this is actually not a place I don't we
representative manage putty thank you Mr
chair
um
I am in full support of
ought to pass for a couple of reasons a
few reasons one is idiot compliance will
bring equipment that's adaptive
equipment to the playground but it does
not address the Ada accessible
playground to caregivers who are
handicapped so you know it could be
adaptive swing adaptive climbing thing
for the kids but 88 in a playground is
not accessed by the adults so from that
angle we need to make sure that the
access to playground as a caregiver
coming to bring a child to a playground
who doesn't need an adaptive equipment
so this addresses that in terms of
surface if I'm in a wheelchair I can do
that
and also having been a speech
pathologist and worked with the multiple
the handicap population disability
population for 30 plus years
I know exactly what the hurdles are in
terms of it and one of the tester monies
referred to the playground that's in my
district and I'm proud to say a lot of
thought was put into it and a lot of
public input and taken into we have a
playground for special needs kids in a
school small one but this is a public
playground and so and I cannot tell you
how many people show up there in such a
joy to watch that to see that it's
accessible not just for the kids adopted
uh
uh people with disability kids with
disability but also the caregivers and
the cost of doing something right from
the get-go
is a lot less expensive than trying to
redo redo it and so there's a lot
available now so
to make inclusive public spaces is a key
thing it should be Paramount and this
does that and with that I will
representative yokella
thank you
um
when I first saw this bill I was
adamantly opposed to it because I don't
like more
um
restrictions and guidelines and just
like seems like trying to make
everything more complicated but
in the testimony we heard that the
municip there was municipality that put
a a park on a Warren article and was
voted on by the town for X dollars to
make some Park and as a taxpayer you get
the right to be able to vote that up or
down and a lot of that
um amount is based on some Engineers or
or designers estimate of of what is
lawful and and allowed to be put down
there and and oftentimes probably going
to be a low cost you're trying going to
go with the lowest bidder
likely and
um to save the the taxpayers money but
allow the children to have this
playground
and then
um and these
um places are able to bid on some
surface which is technically compliant
but only compliant if it essentially
when it is first installed and then as
soon as someone goes on and plays on it
is is no longer compliant with the Ada
and to
bring it in compliance would require
essentially full-time staff to go out
and make sure this the area is flat and
to avoid that they are going back to the
voters and saying hey
um you you pass this Warren article for
X dollars but now we need why more
dollars either for the staff to to make
it accessible full-time or to redo what
what was
um
done to make it accessible all the time
without having to hire more staff and
and the and the person came and said
that it cost
um you know a half a million dollars
more or any amount of money more when
the taxpayer agreed to X price they
didn't agree to X Plus y price and I
think that that is
um like a hidden cost that is going to
be forced on to the that taxpayer to
make them compliant with the Ada and so
I think that
um in the effort to try and
and ensure that our taxes aren't aren't
uh
like we we know what we're getting into
when we're voting on the Warren article
it's best that the that the Warren
article be uh for a project that will
stay compliant and
um
I think that so for those reasons I
think that this even though it's a rare
occurrence it's occurrence that that
essentially ties the taxpayers to paying
more money and so I'm not not in favor
of that and so that's why I would be
voting in favor of this bill thanks
representative true 11.
thank you Mr chair
um I'm very much in favor of this bill
because it was brought home to me during
the testimony
that
as representative manager Puti said
there may be adaptive equipment on the
playground but there's no way for a
person using
a wheelchair or other sorts of AIDS to
get to that thing and I've been doing
some research
um
and my church is in Portsmouth New
Hampshire we're downtown and we've just
installed uh it's a walkway about as
wide as a half of one of these tables so
about this wide
um on each side of the church and it's a
mixture of crushed stone and there's a
base and I'm waiting for a message back
to tell me what the base is it's
permeable it doesn't have to get raked
every time they use it the stone moves a
little bit but not in the way that
representative yokelo was talking about
we've had it for
six months it's pretty much in place so
I think there's things that are doable
here in New Hampshire not way high
priced and I know that representative
Gilman told me about
um mats they have a rubber matting that
they can put down and make the
the walkway accessible they don't have
to do the whole playground with that but
it makes us a firm surface so I think
there's a couple different ways to do it
when I find out what the next step is
I'll let you all know and I will be
representative Hicks
thank you Mr chair so originally
um thinking about this I was in
agreement with representative Powers
thought and then so I did a little more
thinking on that and talking to people
because for me
doing what's right especially for
children is a no-brainer it's my entire
career
and in this case why not make it more
clear and strengthen that communities do
this for kids in the right way so that
it's not missed because I respect
representative Kellis said but really
for the comments representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair
um I find it interesting that uh two
people on the committee are give are
presenting their uh arguments and
they're kind of against each other where
one is saying we don't need this bill
because uh the Ada Federal rules already
regulate this and the other is saying we
don't need this because it'll cost
people too much when it's already
required by federal law I just wanted to
put that out there as an
um you know there's two ways to look at
this and we have to pick one of them
representative
representative manager put it thank you
Mr chair just to add to it in terms of
accessing and uh you know the kids
before
the you know inclusive communities were
very limited you would see blind child
Crossing or here hard of hearing child
on the street kind of thing so to allude
to individual or small uh existence but
now with the total inclusion and parents
that uh
population with disabilities living with
the families in their own communities
that Community has to accommodate
inclusion mainstreaming which is a
wonderful thing and uh just to enhance
that
to give those uh
children an opportunity to enjoy every
part of their childhood like everybody
else so that inclusion will this bill
will enhance that inclusive nature of a
community and I would urge my colleagues
um so uh I was just looking back over my
notes
um from the hearing and one thing that
caught my eye was
um the municipal associations testimony
now normally
the municipal association's testimony I
can predicted beforehand since they're
pretty principled and make
recommendations based on those
principles but in this case they
actually kind of caught me by surprise
that they were in support of this since
it wouldn't be too great of a
uh burden on towns so um yeah I think
that is something that is worth noting
if this really were going to be a burden
they would have said so
um
and because they they do in fact say
that about
um many other bills that
come before us so
um yeah I I think that shows that
it this is really going to do more good
things than bad things so I think we
seeing none I'll make a couple
um
one of the issues that uh the vice chair
brought up is that the adaos already has
requirements for this the bill itself
talks about rubber matting or other
types of service surfaces
let's be clear there's nothing that
prevents towns from implementing
this onto their playgrounds as it is is
nothing that prevents that from
happening the bill is written uh
actually is an unfunded mandate
um we heard testimony that it costs
hundreds of thousands of dollars to put
in and then it was hundreds of thousands
of dollars to
go back and fix something that
had been done improperly to that
specific item I want to talk
um some of the testimony during the
hearing
I got the impression that this bill was
they were asking for the legislature
to
put in the irsa's
from doing harm to themselves almost
like they're expecting us to somehow
protect the towns from themselves when
the towns are going to put in a
playground or or this type of matting to
for the access to the playground
they ought to be doing their due
diligence
to ensure
that what's going in is correct and not
expecting legislature to say oh
protect us from ourselves by putting in
a law that requires this and this again
there's nothing that prevents talents
from doing what's what's in here now the
Ada already requires it so I will be
representative Brown yes uh thank you Mr
chairman uh as a retired engineer I used
to specify
products for facilities buildings
outside
landscape and all that type of thing I
just reviewed the bill again to make
sure I had it right before I commented
but in this bill it requires either
rubber matting or some type of composite
matting as opposed to allowing concrete
pavers or asphalt for access to these
facilities I just feel like I know when
I built these facilities before I very
often entertained alternatives to what
my initial
specification was to save time or money
and I'm just I just feel that this bill
is limited in that it says it requires
rubber or composite materials to be used
as opposed to allowing Paving or
representative
said did I say that right
sorry where she has a crushed stone with
another material underneath it that
provides adequate access I'm all for
providing adequate access for these
playgrounds I have a nephew that has Ms
and he has difficulty getting around as
well but I think that this bill as it is
limits it I'd be amenable to a bill that
had alternatives to this or allowed
engineered materials to be used to allow
reasonable access for this so for that
reason alone I'm going to vote against
the bill as it is thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair I do note the bill
does provide for alternative surfaces in
its text saying rubber composite
surfacing or a similar resilient solid
surface material
I'm corrected thank you
representative
thank you
um I wanted to comment on the statement
about the unfunded mandate which I think
um a stretch at at Shoe horning the
unfended Mandate uh into this as all the
playgrounds would be optional
um and so no no no state is saying that
you have to ha the state is not saying
you have to have a playground and the
playground needs to be this we're saying
if you build a playground
do this and we do that with
essentially everything like if you have
a police department you have to do this
we don't mandate that you have a police
department in the state it's not because
that's not an unfended mandate right we
don't we don't force people to have you
know fire departments but if you have a
fire department you have to do this like
those types of things are not unfunded
representative priest
thank you Mr chairman um as you most of
you will know I
worked as an urban planner for 44 years
and one of the things I did was Master
plans
and Park and Recreation plans and you
know your final goal was to have parks
that were successful that Drew people
all people
and if the access to these parks are not
there and people are not complying with
the ADA requirements then you have then
nobody uses it
and especially when you have a group of
people
in the United States called disable for
whatever
and they're not they're prohibited to
using these facilities
then you're doing you're not we're not
doing what we're supposed to be doing
and that is looking out for the safety
and Welfare of all people in New
representative Gallagher
um
yes I'd just like to address the
Point
um raised about stopping towns from
harming themselves
um I think
um
yes in general
that's a decent principle to abide by
um towns it sounds awfully film familiar
or similar to um John sturt Mills harm
principle but I don't think it's an
applicable principle here
since the
kids that are using these playgrounds
are not the ones who are voting on
whether to have them or not
so it I yeah it's since they're
two separate groups of people here
I don't think
the whole harm to self relationship
really applies here
um so yeah that's my response to that
point
further questions representative Brown
your Mike's on do you have another one
no
okay seeing no further comments with the
Bill 467 the motion is on the path uh
Vice chairman power no
representative Guthrie
collect votes no
prep and Visalus no
representative Elwood no
representative Brown no
representative stavis yes can you send
that to me
representative
represent 311 yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative priests
yes
oh yes no uh
representative run cannot vote on this
he weren't in the mo in the room when
uh the motion excuse me passes 10 to 10
to 9.
thank you Mr clerk uh this will not
obviously go on the consent calendar uh
for the majority opinion representative
priests
and for the
Minority Report
Diane or
sure sure okay
okay next we have exact session on HB
477 prohibiting Municipal inspections of
owner occupied multi-family units
I have
uh
emotion
yes Mr Mr chair I I move uh
with amendment I have a mem passed out
Amendment uh five uh zero five three
one-h standby representative
the
motion I have is from representative
McDonald
no
you can recognize whoever you want Mr
chair
oh I wrote down wrong sorry
representative veal Keller go ahead
thank you Mr chair
I I move
ought to pass as amended uh HB or on the
amendment zero five three one-h
zero three
or zero five three one h
mm
okay I have
I believe first representative we need
to have a second introduce the amendment
itself first by itself so could you
introduce the amendment that you are
proposing
thank you
Amendment uh three five three one H uh
changes
the the language to make it clear that
uh
the
the exemptions for not uh being subject
to these inspections is only for the
unit where the uh the owner is not
currently renting that owner occupied
unit in any form and so if they choose
did we have a second on that yeah we
already got that represent Kelly
continue thank you thank you Mr chair
um so the
there was some worry that
at some point the owner occupied unit
may become a rented
um unit and there was some
uh concern about that and so this
amendment is just to clarify that that
is not what we are talking about when
we're talking about this bill so thank
you thank you representative
uh discussion uh representative majority
representative priest could you turn
your mic off please thank you
thank you Mr chair
um having just seen the the amendment
now this may be my question may be easy
to answer but I don't know what the
answer is
um on line nine it says the legislative
body May enact a process for the
enforcement of the State Building Code
can a local legislative body enact an
enforcement
of a State Building Code
oh that's the existing language okay
thank you Mr chair
um I just have one question
um for representative yukela which you
may or may not choose to answer
which is what if the owner is renting
representative Kelly you may answer that
thank you
um for recognizing me um I believe that
that would not that that renting
wouldn't they wouldn't be the owner then
they would be a rental it would be a
rental just no day
no different than
um
the rental next door I don't I guess I
guess I would
um yeah I think that it would count as a
rental and wouldn't be covered by this
exemption anymore so
for the quest uh comments representative
thank you Mr chair for
um taking my comment I'm going to be
opposing this bill although I understand
some of the rationale behind
um representative Barry's
wanting to put it forward and process it
I think a multi-family unit
all the units should be as safe as one
another and this is about safety it's
not about privacy
um I would even go so far as to say if
my town enacted a code where they wanted
my single family home to be inspected
for code issues every three years I'd be
fine with that because
um you know you can have a fire you can
have a
a mishap with a tree falling on your
house you can all sorts of things happen
that might be preventable the tree could
be preventable prevented by taking it
down before it gets to that point the
fire obviously being sure that your
electricity is up to code that your wood
stoves are installed properly
um
so
for the
comment representative fix
um thank you Mr chair I respectfully
disagree with my friend representative
11 about having inspections of my home
um but here the person is a landlord who
is choosing to rent out a unit and make
money
um on that unit and there are already
Provisions for inspection I don't
understand and from the testimony it
seem to be
um
well let's just say it's a choice to go
that route instead of just have a
private home so I think there's a
difference
representative Gallagher
um so
um speaking to the amendment
specifically
um or yeah I noticed that
um
well it it changes more than just the
part that was mentioned about
um
about uh what the inspection applies to
I see it moves it to a completely
different part of the rsas
um from 155 to
674 which I I noticed just because it's
like hey wait a second what happened to
this other section from the
um original legislation
um
so you're yeah I guess this is a
question
um to representative yokella um if he
wishes to answer ask who
um why
representative Kelly you make or may not
answer the question
I can't answer because I didn't
understand the question so I'm not in
represent majority
well it's it's the same question why the
original Bill wanted to thank you Mr
chair the original Bill wanted to amend
155-a-7 Roman 3. this new Amendment
wants to amend 674.
74 51.
Roman I
so
I'm just I'm trying I'm trying to catch
up and I I remember hearing on the floor
the other day if we don't understand
then we should vote no and right now I
don't know that I understand what the
difference is and I so I apologize that
I didn't ask a question but I'm with you
representative Gallagher that I'm just a
little confused
representative yakella sure thank you
um
thank you for clarifying the question
it is my understanding that it was moved
because the inspectors did not want
um it in the section on the um
on the building code they wanted it
and so it's it's to appease the um
some stakeholders the the placement
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair
um about grammatical comment on the
amendment and also a procedural question
for the committee
um if we have a bill before us that
amends a given existing statute and we
are given an amendment that amends a
different statute is that proper
and that and my comment on the grammar
is in line
16 going to line 17 it says relating to
permitting the unit for renting without
the owner's consent
I have no idea what that means is it the
owner can't consent to renting is it
that the owner doesn't consent it just
makes no grammatical sense so I don't
understand it and I wonder about the
permissibility of us accepting amendment
that it amends a different law than the
bill that we heard testimony on amends
foreign
seeing none will ask the clerk to call a
okay HP
467 and drop the amendment zero five
three one h
representative Guthrie
click votes no representative lasalles
yes
representative uh your Kayla yes
uh representative Elwood yes
yes
Representatives Davis no
representative Tatro
Representative no thank you
representative Gilman no representative
majority no representative
no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks no
representative rung no
representative Priest No
and Mr chairman yes
uh motion fails eight to twelve the
floor is open for another motion do I
have a motion
representative priests
yes Mr chairman I move that we
I'm sorry 477.
which one was that representative Bruce
no I got it I'm sorry is there a second
representative uh representative Hicks
would you like to speak to your emotion
yes I think we're here to protect the
wealth Bill and safety of our residents
and when you have a development like
this
a duplex
a Triplex or a quadplex
what you do in one unit affects all
units and it doesn't matter if your
owner occupy or not
so I believe the building inspections
and regulations should stand forth thank
you
for the representative Hicks I'll just
thank you I'll just reiterate that's a
for the comments
seeing none will ask the clerk to call a
role
HP 477 motion is itl uh Vice chairman
power no
representative Guthrie
click votes yes represent lasalles no
uh represent your color no
representative Kelly no
no if I would no
representative Brown
Representatives Davis yes representative
yeah
representative chair 11 yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative wrong yes
representative priests yes
and Mr chairman no
uh motion passes 12 to 8. hey 12-8 I
assume this will not go on the consent
calendar for the majority report
okay that closes the execs on 477 we'll
open up the executive session on hb4
eight five and I Look to representative
yokella
thank you
um I motion to itl HB 485 thank you do
we have a second
I second it Mr chairman
thank you representative
would you like to speak your motion
representative
thank you as
um I just want to start by addressing
the testimony that we have received from
the
um
New Hampshire Sheriff's Sheriff's
Association today opposing this
um bill they believe that while they're
in favor of more training they
um
uh the training requirement would be in
intensive extensive and
um essentially would be an unfunded
mandate to them
to
spend money on this when they their
budgets are already tight and
um that they feel that they that their
current supportive role to
municipalities is appropriate I also
um
think that uh the sponsor really should
have considered
um addressing that 91 or the um 20 28a
issue by uh assigning this to the state
level
um and that would have been I think more
uh receptive at least or I at least from
my perspective I would have been more
um and the fact that there is such a
small amount of these cases
um is another reason why the state level
operation and training seems to make
sense instead of the county level so for
all those reasons
um I think that itale is the proper
motion thank you
represents Davis
it could be a small amount of these
cases because the reporting is so spotty
so I will be
sorry did you make a motion to Ito
I will not be supporting the motion to
itl because I believe that um
unreported or uncoordinated responses to
animal cruelty
other than cruelty to horses is not
representative of Elwood
thank you Mr chairman I don't think this
bill really goes far enough in speaking
to reporting uh there's no requirements
to report say to a repository maintained
by the state vet let's say
and so it's a feel-good bill to me and
unless it's serves a further purpose to
coordinate these cases I'm going to be
voting Ito
thank you representative uh
representative Gallagher
um
so I'd just like to note that the prime
sponsor included an amendment
uh when she presented
her bill however I think the current
motion is on the bill as unamended
correct so
um yeah I
would like a chance to discuss the
amendment
so I will be
opposing the motion of itl so that
had saw representative Kelly's hand up
no
hi um thank you Mr chair
um I would like to agree with
representative stavis that these cases
are frequently under reported and in
light of the fact that we live in a
society that undervalues animals by Epic
Proportions
I have seen firsthand in my own
neighboring Community where cases are
purposely dropped because it's more
trouble than it's worth to people
sometimes to to defend animals they
think it's too expensive or too much
trouble or evidence is stolen I know
firsthand of those cases and I
personally would prefer to make the
effort to have someone who aggressively
pursues animal cruelty so
um I will be opposing the Ito
representative majority
thank you Mr chair
um I want to support the itl motion I'm
an animal lover I I can't even stand to
watch those commercials that we see on
TV with it I turn them off it just
breaks my heart I can cry in an instant
however I I I I don't see the the uh I
was about to say I don't see the teeth
in this bill I guess I did say that and
I I shouldn't have said that but I don't
see where this where this bill
um is going to enhance the current
statutes for animal cruelty that exist
already
um
uh I I and I guess I'll just leave it at
that that I'll support the itl thank you
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair
um sorry if I interrupted you
so a number of years ago I took in a
stray cat on my doorstep that had been
shot about 13 years ago
and I reported it
and nothing was done about it and I had
the cat for a long time until he passed
away and when he passed away I had to go
to a vet and some questions came up and
then I had sheriffs asking questions
like 13 years later after I had filed
out a police report about the cat being
shot so while I love animals
I don't trust this organization to
follow through and do anything about it
and I would agree with Mr yokella
possibly on the state agency being in
representative
down the end pretty soon
uh thank you Mr chairman I don't think
this is a heavy lift on our County
Sheriff's
for something that has been for so long
ignored and
just Swept Away
and
having grown up and raised horses
nothing is you know more cruel than to
see horses mistreated
and having no Avenue around to report
this
thank you
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman
um as you know the
hi Sheriff from Carroll County submitted
a letter of testimony
indicating that he didn't feel it was
necessary I've had 11 years working with
the police in the town of moultonborough
never had any complaints the police seem
to do a good job with that and I haven't
heard any complaint from the
constituents and the other two towns
that I represent so I would vote to it
all this thank you representative uh
Hicks well thank you Mr chair I'm a
little unclear how this is going to
increase reporting versus once reporting
our report has been made action being
taken so I don't quite understand that
so and I think that this is a heavier
lift then representative priest said
especially being completely understaffed
in Merrimack County Sheriff's Department
this would put quite a burden on that
department thank you
representative power thank you Mr
chairman
um I'd like to follow up and along with
what the previous member said in a prior
member may have also
said this as well but my concern is with
the um the increased costs that this
bill would
represent if it were signed into law we
did get testimony from the New Hampshire
Sheriff's Association
um expressing concerns that this um
could cost counties quite a bit of of
money
and that
it may require additional deputies with
um to to receive this training and they
also specified
um
purchasing perhaps another vehicle
and they also indicated in their letter
of testimony supporting itl that
training requirements could include the
possibility of the sheriff's deputy
having to attend an academy to become a
certified law enforcement officer so for
those
cons for those reasons I have concern
with cost associated with this so I will
be supporting itl
representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair
from my notes from the public hearing
um
New Hampshire Sheriff's Association
lobbyist or representative had no
position on this and also the training
question came up and I don't recall who
did that but currently the training in
the police academy exists it's just
added to the deputy because currently
only the deputies can take a complaint
or report a complaint or investigate if
it is the officer below the deputy
cannot do that and considering that
animals are voiceless creatures and
unless we human advocate for them
they can't advocate for themselves
and uh so from that
but last but not the least
our colleague who left us last here who
was a strong advocate
of animal
protection representative Rogers would
be smiling down to say we did what is
right for the animals so with all that I
will be voting against itl and I would
do
for the comments seeing nonetheless the
ihp 485 the motion is itl vice chairman
power yes
clerk votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Keller yes
representative Alward yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill
Representatives Davis no
representative Tatro no representative
311 no
representative Gilman no
representative majority
no
representative
absolute now
representative Gallagher
no
representative Priest No
and Mr chairman yes
motion passes 11 to 9. thank you Mr
clerk assuming this will go on to the
regular calendar
uh representative yokella committee
me
representative man chaputi raised her
okay that clear this is the exact on 485
we'll open up the exec session House
Bill 526 regulating temporary
traffic control Personnel that I have a
motion representative Brown
yes Mr chairman I need to retain this
bill
do I have a second
uh representative lasalles I will second
there thank you representative
representative Brown would you like to
speak yes Mr chairman I just don't think
there's adequate information right now
to make this determination the language
thank you representative for the
comments
representative lasalles
we have a
an issue right now with
Staffing
and
um filling all the opening open
positions that we have
for police
you might think well if we do this bill
then that would relieve some of the
duties
of the police and free them up but
testimony that we got and individual
feedback that I got was that this would
be seen by
police departments
as a negative morale booster
so with with respect to what's happening
right now with police departments I
think the timing on this bill
is wrong so I will be supporting the
retain I'm all for saving money and I
think there certainly are
um
situations where we can get away with
less than uh a uniformed police officer
I just think right now the timing is bad
I'll be supporting retaining the bill
thank you representative
seeing no further comment we'll ask the
oh I'm sorry I didn't see your hand up
there representative Hicks thank you Mr
chair just quickly
um I will support retaining this bill I
do hope that in the discussion it isn't
a point of emphasis that police officers
rely on the duty to make more money I I
don't think that should be the point of
yeah
for the comments
okay now we'll have the uh
you do no I don't know I was told I had
a comment but I don't
know I
khp 526 the motion is to uh retain
uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes
uh representative Keller yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Howard yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes
yes Representatives Davis yes
representative Tetro yes representative
tree 11 yes representative Gilman yes
representative Mega pootie no
representative Gallagher yes
representative of hicks yes
and Mr chairman yes
uh motion pass is 17 to 3. I think Mr
clerk HP 526 is retained in committee
open up the second to last bill for exec
representative Edward Mr chairman I move
that house bill 636 to itl
thank you representative representative
power seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
yes Mr chairman thank you
um apparently the prime sponsor was a
no-show and there was no substantive
information upon which any informed
decisions could be made
thank you very much
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman I would just like
to comment that as a selectman that the
board of adjustment on occasion
depending on the town is an elected
official
and I suggest to you you might have a
real problem getting rid of an elected
official
because he didn't take a test
and I think the uh the intent of the
bill is a good one to provide this kind
of training I think it is available and
All Aboard of adjustment to members
should be knowledgeable of what's going
on it's a very very important position
but I just think it's set up in a way
that that is
just it's on weirdly if if anything else
and I would suggest that the uh the
information for the board of adjustment
representative Gilman thank you Mr chair
I'd like to repeat the remarks that were
just said I I believe it would have a
dampening effect on zoning board
membership
um also the bill references the
the office of the office of business and
development and the office of Planning
and Development already provide this
training so I don't understand why
they'd want to move it from one one
office to another
I think that's it
thank you I'm going to make a quick
comment here as a general rule
um
we in the committee believe that if a
individual sponsor cannot attend his own
bill that
we will normally
send that bill to the dust heaps if we
need to keep talking about this we can
but I think we're all headed in the
right direction
or the same direction I should say not
foreign
HB 636 motion is itl
uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly yeah
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes representative Cahill
representative stavis yes representative
yes representative yes representative
Gilman
yes representative majority yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher
uh yes representative Hicks
representative wrong yes
representative priest yes and Mr
chairman yes uh motion pass is 20-0
unless there's an objection this will go
on the consent calendar I see no
objections onto the calendar it goes
that closes the hearing on
what's that oh report uh who was it that
made the motion point of order Mr
representative Elwood we'll do that uh
go ahead reporter excuse me
um there's a fiscal note on this so can
it go on consent or does it can we it's
actually it can go unconscious okay
for some reason it goes through and they
say it can't we'll make it we only had
one bill that's going to a technically
second committee
and that was the one we did this morning
so
um
if it has to go on
it'll go but it's
okay we're down to our last bill
HB
51 do I have a motion
from representative your Keller yes
thank you Mr chair I would like to um
move uh Amendment
0399h for uh be 51.
do I have a second representative power
seconds would you like to speak to your
Amendment thank you yes this this
amendment replaces the entire Bill and
it was
um on your on your table
this morning
and
um
it
um says that
instead of having a warned article being
required for
these for each lobbying firm that that
the
associations
that
members are Town School Districts or
local public officials those
associations shall have membership fees
and lobbying fees be separately stated
and the lobbying fee be an optional
B and not contingent on their membership
or the membership not be contingent on
on that paying of that lobbying fee so
that allows more flexibility at the
local municipality that they could
either for
financial reasons choose to
um
to Avail themselves of the training of
such a membership fee but not uh the
lobbying fee that might be accompanying
with it or they could do it because of
the lobbying would go against some
principle that that they do not uh wish
to espouse or for whatever reason
um the the local municipality will be
able to fully
discuss the cost the the cost and the
benefits of the the lobbying efforts of
each of the associations and could take
or leave that with
um which right now it is
um part and parcel of the membership fee
and so it is
um part of the cost
and maybe
um also taking taxpayer money and and
uh lobbyists that would espouse
um things that the people paying for it
would not
um be comfortable with uh supporting and
so taking taxpayer money and using it
for
for a lot this type of lobbying
should only be done essentially with the
consent of those people those taxpayers
and so this this amendment would allow
those taxpayers the right to
um
to make that decision which currently
they're not able to do so thank you
thank you representative representative
majority
thank you Mr chair if
I'm understanding that the amendment
replaces the entire Bill okay so uh at
this point to the best of my knowledge
uh communities have the ability to know
everything that is being that they are
spending their money on and should I
know I'll speak only to my town uh we
have a line item for uh for all of our
lobbying efforts for our lobbying
organizations contained within our
budget our budget additionally the
budget committee then can ask questions
about where are those fees going or who
is getting those fees that information
is absolutely readily available and also
to the best of my knowledge any
represent or excuse me any citizen of
the town can can file a petition with 25
other 25 24 other people to to restrict
those lobbying efforts through any one
organization to add any lobbying efforts
from an organization so I think what
this bill is trying to do is already
readily available to any Community out
there I also don't understand
how an organization in this effort is
going to be able to parse their training
from their lobbying I see that as being
I I'm not I I just maybe it's just a not
a mature thought yet but I can't
understand how an organization that's
going to give a training on
um on 674 land use
would then not be able to lobby for
those same efforts to improve the
statute so I I don't support the
amendment at all and and have other
thoughts but that's all I have right now
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to say
first of all that I really wanted to
vote for this I had it my notes on the
front of my uh my paperwork that I
ought to pass uh and then after further
thinking as a selected and in my town
it's to pretty much transparency too I
get concerned about as I said before
what's wrong with the word lobbying and
what is lobbying I mean is that a bad
word I mean is it something like uh it's
not a four-letter word it's just I think
there's more than four letters in it so
it's not something we have to clean up
off the floor
so I would suggest to you that it's
lobbying means getting help uh
information from a group or a person and
you know where that's coming from and I
think that's the key you know where it's
coming from you can either reject it or
accept it but as a public official I
need that information
uh either it's at a local level at this
level as long as I know where it's
coming from I have a option to make make
it a break it and I think this sometimes
this somewhat uh hampers the ability for
us to work in concert with people who
are trying to help us
so I don't think I'm changing my mind
I'm gonna have to change my mind when we
vote
because although I understand the intent
uh particularly of the amendment you
know trying to get making make sure that
we're getting the money's going to the
right place uh and I condemn I commend
that not condemn it I amend commend that
uh but I'm not going to be able to
support this bill
thank you Mr Jim representative
thank you Mr chair I completely agree
with my colleague representative Guthrie
on the points that he made one person's
lobbying as another person's expertise
in a necessary field and my well one of
my concerns with the amendment
is that I do feel that it creates an
unfunded mandate because who in city
hall or town hall is going to be
responsible for singling out what's
education from what's lobbying and
making sure that those bills are paid
are not paid and I and I also have a
concern about
the author of the amendment statement
that people shouldn't be required to pay
for views they disagree with
so does that mean that should the people
in the town change their views that they
can then re-adopt the people advising
them so it's very confusing to me and it
seems to be an infringement on freedom
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair I'm also confused by
the phrase or the local public officials
thereof and whether that means that a
fellow select board member can cannot
come before this commission for say and
Lobby for an or against uh bill that
we're we're discussing
um it's a local public official and it
could even be uh someone from our town
manager Department of Public Works who
has a specialty in what we're talking
about so if that's what this means I
foreign
thank you Mr chair when I was on
Municipal and County government last
term this bill or something similar came
forward and it's it's really unworkable
at the local level and I Echo what
representative Guthrie had said but in
my situation
um in
our Local School board chairman a few
years ago was on the board for the New
Hampshire school boards Association so
it's not as though these associations
are
isolated they're member organizations so
people that are on these boards and
Boards of selectman school board
whatever they're actually part of this
Association so I don't really know how
you can delineate
um discussions of those members who may
sit on those boards from what is just
informative educational to what is
lobbying there is such a big gray area I
think it this would create such a undue
and unnecessary burden on our local
municipalities so I'm going to vote for
the itl or vote against the ought to
pass
representative lasalles
I'm sorry the amendment I'll be voting
thank you thank you Mr chairman
um
I'm currently Citizen selectman and I
previously served for three terms as a
school board member in my town of
Litchfield
as a school board member there were
times when I felt that the school boards
Association had an agenda
which was an agenda that was completely
against what I as a school board member
had and it was it was um
against what the what the overwhelming
majority of the people
who had elected me as as a school board
member that they were they were pushing
something else and they feel that
because the school boy there are people
who feel that because the School Board
Association has a particular feeling
about something that has instant
credibility
and I always
felt that I that that was a stab in my
back now I'm currently a selectman
there's hardly a meeting that goes by
when the Selectmen or the Town
Administrator doesn't say well we need
to talk to the municipal Association
and and they perform a valuable service
and when a member of the municipal
Association comes and speaks to us here
I don't feel that they are lobbying even
if they were lobbying you know I can
tell them to go jump off a cliff
you know I'm gonna make up my own mind
now their input is valuable
but
I don't have to accept that and because
uh they're from the municipal
Association that doesn't mean that
they're all knowing about something
now I do have to say
that I I disagree or I'm sorry I agree
with my uh my fellow committee members
that I don't see how this would work I
really don't as much as I dislike
paying for uh when I was on the school
board as much as I dislike paying for
the school board association dues
I I just don't see how you can break
that out into lobbying or information
because as
my respected uh
compatriot
representative Davis said one person's
lobbying is another person's information
so I I just don't feel that it would
work and I'm I'm going to be in trouble
here because my running mate there
representative Baum this is a dream that
he's had for years so
um
uh but I I have to say that I just don't
representative power thank you Mr
chairman so I see this bill as well as
this amendment and what it's doing is
it's it's dividing the function right
now
municipalities and school districts they
pay for a they pay a fee for a service
and that service is is a combined
service it's it's training it's
information it could be
legal services if you will opinions and
then it's the lobbying piece of it that
this funding goes to those purposes with
respect to these organizations
and to me lobbying is when the the the
employees of these organizations come
here
to Concord and sit at the witness table
and they're wearing orange tags
because of their lobbyists they have to
register with the secretary of state so
I let's be very clear about that and to
me what this is is allowing at the local
level
and all are caught
I guess
Services if you will if they if locally
a school board or a
municipality wants to
have these services that they can pay
for them or they can do one or either or
both
and it just separates it out so
um so
uh to the
so to the points
um that Representatives
um acellus got three and save us were
raising about the
um difficulty or
um the fine line between
distinguishing between providing
information versus
lobbying where it sometimes hard to tell
um I I'd just like to say I do kind of
share uh
the
um this bill's sponsors distaste for
getting information from lobbyists but
the thing is it is useful information
though like
when the municipal Association provides
the information to us oftentimes it
helps us clean up the bills and make
them better just because
um
you know they're good at catching typos
and mistakes and stuff like that now
if we wanted
to
have
another
way of doing this like perhaps by
funding OLS better so that they can hire
more drafting attorneys to
catch mistakes for us then okay then
maybe we wouldn't need the municipal
Association as much but this bill
doesn't do that though so
um yeah I I don't think
I don't think we can uh decrease the
municipal associations role unless
we increase our loss's role instead so
um I can't support this
thank you Mr chairman
I'm looking at the definition of Lobby
and it's a group of people seeking to
influence politicians or public
officials on a particular issue
it doesn't say provide training it
doesn't say
information
now I know that as a citizen or a
taxpayer I cannot walk into town hall
and say give me the password to the
portal that gets me into nhma so that I
can benefit from everything the
municipality is benefiting from
dues that is paid is funded by the
taxpayers they should have full benefit
and have full input into how the town
interacts with these associations and by
no means do I mean any disrespect
to the representatives from nhma here
today
I I fully depend on the information I'm
able to access but
what your what this bill is doing is
allowing the taxpayer to decide not the
municip not the town government to
decide what the political position of
the town is
and that's how I read what this bill is
representative majority
thank you Mr chair I think back to the
FairPoint litigation and wonder how I
would be able to as a selectman remember
the select board in my town be able to
explain to my community the value of
getting information from Comcast to and
the assessors Association to fully
understand what that litigation would
imply I don't know how I could explain
that to my voters to get Authority when
that information is also readily
available under statute RSA 15 requires
that all fees from lobbying be reported
so it is I just we rely on that
information it's incredibly valuable and
maybe fluid at times in a way that if I
had to do it by warrant article and
request would be untenable
thank you
representative yokella
thank you and since it's fresh in my
mind I'll just address the um recent
comment about Warren articles there is
no worn article requirement in this bill
um so or under in this amendment so that
is is not not an issue and also I wanted
to address the the comment before about
how municipalities can already do this
and as a budget Committee Member
um who would like to make a motion to
not fund the lobbyists
um
[Music]
but still want to be a member of nhma
or or Municipal is or uh the School
Board Association or whatever
um I know that I am not able to make
that motion and because they there is no
option for
um for being a member of the municipal
Association without the lobbying fee
currently and what this amendment seeks
to do is to allow me as a budget
Committee Member to be able to make that
motion or for a citizen with a warrant
article to be able to make that motion
and say no we're going to do the
municipal Association or or the School
Board Association membership but we are
going to have a robust discussion about
the lobbying efforts and I also want to
um
touch on what is the distinction between
lobbying because and and information
because it keeps on getting passed
around as far as like there is some
confusion
there is no confusion it's written into
law what is lobbying and what is not
lobbying and lobbying is not giving
information you're able to go to the
municipal Association whether or not
that um you paid for the lobbying
to get information from them lobbying is
in statute under RSA 15 colon 1 it says
to promote or oppose directly or
indirectly any legislation
so it if you asked the any of these
associations a question
about not saying whether they oppose or
or for the bill but trying to gather
information that is not lobbying
lobbying is when they say this bill
should die or this bill should be be
passed that is what is lobbying and and
to
um representative Gilman's question
about
um people
um if a selectman or any other person in
the town in the in the local officials
would be able to quote lobby at the
State House the this this uh I'm this
paragraph is only about the association
what the association can do that you're
a member of and so if those members are
associated uh part of an association
then the association has a lobbying arm
under current law the the amount the
money spent on lobbying has to have a
separate bank account
under current law the the money for for
lobbying has to be separate
and all this is doing is making that
instead of being able to transfer in and
out of that separate bank account for
lobbying now you have dedicated funds
for that lobbying
that that money goes into a bucket for
lobbying and so you wouldn't be having
this transferring in and out of
some amount of money unknown at the time
and really what this is coming down to
is not about
defunding or funding any particular
organization it is about giving the the
local voters and the local budget
committee members the local Selectmen
the opportunity to make the decision
right now they currently do not have the
opportunity to make the decision it's a
take it or leave it option right now
you're either part of the N8
um the nhma or the School Board
Association or the um the clerks
Association you you're all in or nothing
right now I'm saying that there is some
value in the training
absolutely and so people often want to
keep get access to that training but
there may be philosophical issues or
differences and it's not even at the
Town level because the town doesn't have
the right to to
um to tell nhma that they cannot do some
lobbying on some Bill if if my town
let's say my Selectmen all vote that
they like hb44
like they cannot go to the municipal
Association and say you cannot Lobby on
this right they would have to come here
themselves and do their own lobbying on
it
because
the majority of towns voted for specific
policies
whether or not my specific Town agrees
with those policies those are the
policies and if my my town does not
agree with those policies
maybe they should not be forced to fund
them they should be able to come here
and say no we disagree with those
policies and that's why we didn't give
them the money this year
for whatever reason it could be on any
issue it could be on you know uh you
know electric charging stations and and
requiring electric charging stations the
municipality say that's an unfunded
mandate we don't like it but maybe
Portsmouth really wants to have electric
charging stations that that should be
their choice and if they don't want to
fund that I think you know and they want
to come up here and represent themselves
I encourage them to do so thank you
I'm sorry thank you
um and so thank God that the New
Hampshire Municipal Association was
there because they gave them the voice
they gave them the voice to to the
legislature on matters that concerned
all cities and towns
and besides that all of the great
education and and information that they
have so I I will be opposing this
amendment and opposing this Bill thank
you
did I see representative Brown's hand up
before
Mr chairman thank you for recognizing me
I did want to uh agree with
representative lasalles on a number of
points I was a school board member as
well and felt that I was well trained by
the School Board Association when I
initially became a school board member
but I also felt that I was being lobbied
for positions that I didn't necessarily
hold or the people in my town but also
um
I've seen was the New Hampshire
Municipal Association which covers a
broad range of topics when I first came
on this committee I was like holy cow
they really cover the whole topic and
since I've been here they seem to
represent themselves as far as providers
of information not necessarily lobbyists
but I also wanted to point out to the
committee members that every job that
I've ever had in my life I was able to
track how many hours I did on one part
of my job and another part of my job
when I was a project manager I tracked
the hours for each project that I
managed so and
you know lawyers do that most
professional organizations track their
hours and assign them to particular
projects so I'd say it's it is doable as
far as tracking your cost and splitting
those costs up
but it does take some additional work
representative McDonald
uh thank you Mr chairman
I wish we wouldn't just look at two
groups the municipal Association the
school district this bill is going to
affect a whole bunch of people and I was
just going I'm on the budget Community
my time been on for about 30 years and
these are some of the groups that we pay
for dues for the employees we pay the
New Hampshire police Chiefs Association
Tax Collectors Association the assess
Association town clerk Association
county attorney's group we've got the
association of counties which I'm sure
your counties belong to we pay the New
Hampshire Bob Association we pay the
recreational direct to be part of epoxy
Rec Association
New Hampshire Sheriff's Association New
Hampshire Fire Chiefs Association and
then we have got a whole bunch of other
people other groups that we pay on the
national level like National Police
achieve police Chiefs and firemen and
things like that all these groups are
going to be affected by this by this
amendment okay it's not just the
municipal folks and the school teaches
it's going to be everyone that we that
our towns the communities our counties
pay for to belong to something
and I think it's uh it's unreasonable I
I feel it's an attack on those two
groups the municipal Association the
school teachers and there's other ways
of solving the problem on the local
level if you want to address it either
through a a loan article or you can come
into a budget meeting and tell your
budget members could you please take
this out we don't want to pay for this
thank you Mr chair I'm so upset that I
for the comments
seeing none I have just a couple quick
ones
um
what I'm going to do is give you an
analogy that I brought up in our caucus
this morning about this bill
I'm a dues-paying member of 38 years for
the pilots Union that I work with
and what they do is they segregate the
funding between union dues which goes
for the education contract compliance
training a lot of things that the pilots
Union do
but they also have
a pack
political action committee
which is used specifically for lobbying
that part of our the dues although we're
a you know you can be a member or not
you still pay a portion of your dues
even if you're not a member I've been in
full who's paying for 38 years
the pilots aren't always as a lot of
some of the issues that have been
brought up are not always on board with
sometimes where our Union goes you can
go in and out of the pack you can you
know you can start your contributions
you can stop your contributions but it's
it is segregated
um I personally like that I do pay for
my pack because that is specifically for
lobbying and I believe we get
value out of that I will say there was a
two-year period where I would stop
paying because I didn't like where they
were going
um
I don't somebody mentioned uh you know
lobbyist is bad word I don't see
lobbyists as a bad word at all
and I don't think this is where this
bill goes the bill is going simply to
separate the two pots of money which I
do not disagree with
um
the last thing and it kind of goes along
with the my analogy of my Pilots Union
it's not all
towns want or need the same thing
especially if you've got cities like
Manchester Nashua their needs and wants
may be different than
my town of Barrington or representative
Brown's Town of moultonborough or
somebody's Town up in Cross County
so
um I I don't see this as attack I don't
see this attack on anybody in this room
or anybody that comes before us at all
it to me it is a way of segregating out
the funds I'm not opposed to that so I
will vote in favor of it thank you
and seeing no further comments less the
clerk to call the rule
khb 51 and it's adopt the amendment
Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes no
representative Visalus no
your Kayla items I'm sorry it's been a
long day my friend
yes
yes okay
uh representative Kelly yeah
representative Elwood yes
representative Brown
Representatives Davis no
representative Pedro no
Mr clerk I'm sorry could you tell me
what I'm voting on right now it's been a
long day HB 51
OTP adopt the amendment 399h uh no thank
you you're welcome ma'am
uh representative Gilman no
representative majority no
representative mangaputi
no
representative Gallagher
representative Hicks no
representative run no
representative Priest No
and Mr chairman
yes
motion fails 6 to 14. thank you do I
have another motion
representative majority
yes Mr chair thank you I move itl on
House Bill 51.
do we have a second on that
further discussion I do have a question
for you Mr chair
the bill House Bill 51 is different than
the amendment
that's correct but I'm going to wave off
comments okay I think that's a wise
decision
is there any further comment
if you have your microphone on can you
please turn them all off there's a bunch
on thank you
okay so you know further comments ask
the clerk to call the roll
HB 51 the motion is itl uh Vice chairman
power no
representative Guthrie
clerk votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Keller no
representative Kelly
representative Elwood no representative
I could turn on your mic representative
uh representative yes
representative
yes representative tree eleven yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority
yes representative megapudi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
wrong yes
representative priest yes
and Mr chairman no
promotion passes 15 to 5.
okay motion fifteen to five uh
is there anybody on the minority side
who would like to do a makes is there
any opposition to going on to the
consent calendar yes yeah okay so we'll
go on to it it will go on to the regular
calendar uh for the majority who will be
writing the committee report
and the
Minority Report representative yukela I
see you over there if you want it or
representative power
yeah
it was done I love doing the day with
you
um so we'll close the hearing on HB 51.
uh where's my notes
well
I lost my notes
um good idea
error
no it's still on the floor
now
okay
too late
okay we still are we we are still being
recorded
um so with that today believe it or not
we
had public hearings and exit exact
49 bills and as of today we believe it
or not are completed which is to me well
done I would also like to say I was very
suspicious on doing 18 bills today
we were able to get
18 bills exact which is uh very very
good
um
I would expect next week we have two
days of sessions uh house sessions I
would expect to be see some of our bills
from last week that we execed on
on at least one of the two days I'm not
sure which day that'll be uh once once
that is published that will be published
tomorrow night
what we'll need to do is get together on
the bills where we have uh floor debates
Representatives Davis and I and we'll
need to get together and just figure out
who we'll be doing the
floor debating on that and we will get
other than that we have a number of
retained bills I will
get those together and get a list out so
we all know which ones are actually
retained
and other than that that's all I have I
think
representative
my question is um regard to the retained
bills
I know we talked earlier about having a
deadline
when will we get started will you let us
know about doing that yeah absolutely
that's why I said after today I want to
get the list of them together and then
go from there yet I talked with the
clerk and we have there is a date in the
fall that we have to have a disposition
on them and then they will go to the
floor
um first thing next year great thanks so
much
representative
thank you Mr chair I'd once again like
to commend
all of my committee mates on Municipal
and County Government
for an extraordinary exact session of 18
bills and also especially the chair and
the vice chair
for the way they have organized
everything and
just our Delight to work with and so I'd
like to just give a shout out to
thank you all right any further comments
thanks representative
thank you Mr chair I hate to be the
naysayer but I feel very offended for
not being recognized it's it's almost
like
it's gotten to me that this will be the
last time I'll be in this committee
because it's somehow I feel singled out
by you every time I raise my hand it
looked the other way and I'm always the
last person to be recognized and it's
really very personal to me and I've been
invisible and I'm sorry
to say that but it's really affected I
had a healthy issue I put aside that
came today
to be part because I know that's my duty
to my constituents and
sorry but I needed to express that at
the cost of my health I'm here today and
I'm sorry I was treated that badly
well thank you for the comment uh
representative um as you've seen
throughout the year I have a method of
who is called and when is called I
alternate you'll see me all the time I
alternate my head to the right and the
left the individuals who have spoken
once I allow others to speak before
somebody speaks twice
um I think I've been extremely fair in
how I allocate the those who speak I
also have mentioned before at previous
meetings that
I prefer at times to have if I see
somebody who doesn't speak frequently I
would like to hear them speak
and I always do I prefer to have them
speak first
and then I always get to everybody at
some point so I don't think there's any
certainly any intent to exclude anybody
everybody has spoken one
sure representative 11. thanks
um
now
think representative man dupudi has a
point and it might be where she sits
because both of us are served in the
corner over here
um and it might be another reason but I
think that um
I have to disagree with you a little bit
and and I unders I understand her
feelings of feeling excluded and not
listened to so my suggestion to you
would be that you have a personal
conversation with her and and hear the
whole thing out
because we know your intentions are good
when we disagree we disagree and that's
fine that's what we're supposed to do
um but she's she's received a message
that you say you aren't sending so that
needs to get square between the two of
you is what I think I would note that
what I just discussed
reps the representative who made the
comments was not even in the room she
vacated the room I I understand all
right yeah with that thanks